let's go what do we got jaundice first
one what do we got
so apple will hit a three trillion
dollar market cap and microsoft will
achieve the same milestone not long
after
yeah apple's gonna hit a three trillion
dollar market cap in q1 i'm gonna go
believer
on apple i'm gonna go [ __ ] on
microsoft in 2020 you're basically
betting yeah you're basically betting
here here's my thought process you're
betting do they raise interest rates and
if they raise interest rates do tech
stocks sell off
if they raise interest rates and tech
stocks sell off microsoft doesn't make
it because it won't move up enough in
time but apple probably still has you
know another couple weeks and they can
get there
but if they don't
raise interest rates
then tech stocks don't sell off party
continues and they both hit it okay
the s p 500 will rise with goldman sachs
predicting a nine percent gain for
twenty twenty two i'm gonna go with
believers so it's just gonna be positive
is essentially what we're saying yeah
the i'm gonna say believer but the only
thing that i'm going off of is the
historical return of the s p 500 is like
eight nine percent so i'm just saying
that yeah it's likely to do about
historically what it's done
one of the world's largest banks just
took the average basically and said this
is what we think is going to happen
uh so yeah i'm on board with that
the odds are against us 6.2 for
6.2 percent in 2018 yeah no of course
the stock market definitely goes down in
2008 they lost you know like 38
30 38 but historically it has averaged
you know that seven eight or nine
percent so if you just say it'll rise
the chances are more likely than not yes
i'll vote for this this is going to be
the test can stocks really go up forever
well they're definitely going to go up
forever over long periods of time it's
just a matter of what happens in the
short term of a year but yeah so are you
a believer or [ __ ] that the s p will
be up close to ten percent well let's
say it just goes it just says will rise
yes all right next
inflation expectations remain high
according to bloomberg survey of 47
economy you don't need to survey them as
the world works through supply chain
constraints uh yes
uh i don't think that this inflation is
gonna remain high because of the supply
chain constraints actually in some crazy
way uh there may be inventory uh issues
where they have too much inventory but i
think inflation remains high uh
depending on what your evaluation of
high is let's say two percent or more is
high then inflation is you know in my
opinion definitely going to remain high
but it's more because on discipline
monetary and fiscal policy than it is
because the supply chain you call it
supply chain you call it
price gouging whatever you want to call
it but i'm on board with that it's going
to remain high yes i agree as well all
right next global box office will jump
to 33 billion 58 year over year but the
film industry
will um sorry i'm switching back and
forth but the film industry will have to
wait until 2023 to reach pre-pandemic
levels of 40 billion this all depends on
china
what how do you china is probably the
biggest market for film now like a lot
of these films that launch uh end up
making most of their money in china uh
so one there's tons of censorship that
happens in order to get your film
approved to be distributed in china yeah
shout out i know the facts uh chris
fenton who used to be a very large uh
film uh executive uh was on my podcast
and talked a lot about how they'll do
things like if you have anything that
could be negative towards china
not good uh china is the massive market
for us movies and not only that there's
a period of most people don't know this
and i don't know the exact facts and the
dates but there's a period of the year
in china where you are not where they
don't show american films they don't
show any films outside of chinese
specific films so they only play films
that were made in their own country it's
so it's supposed to basically like
promote their own stuff uh but
ultimately like sometimes it's at like
really bad times for films to be
released here so there's like a schedule
and all of the movies here know it
obviously that when you when you produce
a film or you release a film like you
gotta get in china one and then two it's
gotta be in this certain period of time
we had john cena apologizing yeah
they took a badge off of uh tom cruise's
jacket because he had like a taiwanese
badge or something on one of his jackets
in a movie like there's a lot of crazy
[ __ ] goes on so ultimately this number
just depends on china and i actually
think the geopolitical uh ramifications
have more of an impact on this than uh
consumer demand consumers want to watch
movies we know that right and there's no
reason why they're not gonna be watching
as many movies as they were before uh
that they you know in 2022 i think
ultimately the geopolitical situation if
all of a sudden we get into a u.s first
china and that starts to get ramped up
and china pulls on the lever of how do i
put uh inflict maximum pain on the u.s
cool your movies aren't going to get
distributed here anymore and you wipe
tens of billions of dollars of revenue
from that industry
that's a pretty big chess move the eu
becomes the world's most important tech
referee while u.s anti-trust bills are
stuck in congress regulators in the eu
and uk will continue to bring anti-trust
cases against big tech [ __ ] the eu
bro what
[ __ ] casey newton
actually casey casey newton is very
intelligent actually has has pretty good
thoughts usually but like who cares what
the eu has to say
nobody in the united states cares what
the eu has to say they always data
policies all this nonsense all this
[ __ ] whatever that's why
everything's becoming decentralized
because people literally don't care
anymore the the the eu is playing a game
that they can't win where they literally
keep coming out and they're like oh you
have to uh disclose this you have to do
this [ __ ] guess what the companies just
say okay fine whatever and then they
change the
terms and conditions or they add
something that you opt into or they do
something differently or whatever right
but ultimately the free market is going
to be much bigger of a determinant of
the success of these tech companies than
what the policies of the eu are the eu
just isn't that big of a percentage of
their user base following el salvador's
lead other countries in latin america
such as panama and paraguay could make
bitcoin legal tender could make uh yeah
well yeah we're gonna say we're gonna
say we'll make yeah um i
i don't know about legal tender i think
that that's like a pretty big bar in a
lot of these countries what i will say
is that they will adopt bitcoin and that
could take many different forms legal
tender is one of the things that they
could do in my opinion uh but also they
could start mining they could give it to
uh citizens they put on their balance
sheet like there's a world where a
country puts bitcoin on their balance
sheet but doesn't make it legal tender
so technically this would be false but i
think the spirit of it is that these
countries are going to adopt it and i'll
say i'm a believer on that yeah i think
about it the same way as a quick funding
vehicle decentralized autonomous
organizations will become as hyped in
2022 as special purpose acquisition
companies were in 2021 they already are
not not that they're they are the spax
or not that they're legitimate but they
already are as hyped there's literally
every day i log on to twitter i see
someone trying to do something with the
dow there's probably more dows than
there are specs yeah aggregate numbers
overrated or underrated
overrated in the short term underrated
in the long term yeah i actually think
that there's a likelihood that they uh
come under legal scrutiny in like a very
material way
like i mean look i'm not a lawyer
i'm not a lawyer but you can't say hey
everyone put your money in a pot and
then you're going to get a token in
exchange and then we're going to go do
something and the token price is either
going to go up or down and say that
that's not a security so i think that's
going to be a hard sell um again uh i
think that over the long term we're
drastically underrate underestimating it
but it all goes back to this idea that
right now all people are trying to do is
they're trying to take this idea of a
decentralized autonomous organization
and they're trying to have it replace
a company or replace a entity like
that's not how technology works instead
what people should be doing is saying to
themselves what is it that uniquely is
unlocked from a user experience or
utility standpoint by this type of
vehicle that is now available or
possible that previously wasn't and so
if you think go back to like uber uber
only happens because the iphone comes
out with gps in it before that phones
didn't have a gps in like a mainstream
uh consumer way and therefore you
couldn't have uber but the second that
this device came out had gps in it now
all of a sudden the driver and the rider
both have gps we can have them meet
and so the same thing here is you got to
think about what is the native use case
what is the native thing to these
technologies not how do we just get
around restarting a company
right yeah i get it it's faster it's
cheaper all that stuff for sure
but it's also probably in the gray area
from a legal standpoint and so you're
trying to just use new technology to
replace old things like no it's what's
the new thing what's the native thing to
it that now is impo is empowered that
previously wasn't that's where i think
the real value is short term drastically
overrated long term underrated for what
uh people will figure out use cases for
or uh applications that nobody has even
talked about yet apple
apple will acquire a film tv studio to
better compete with its streaming
competitors will apple get basically
into this like full into the streaming
and content producing game i i don't
think that uh this is that controversial
yeah they will right like yeah i guess
maybe they don't have a studio
themselves but don't they already they
acquire films and don't they already
make their own or no i think so but do
you think it's smart to basically
continue on the path that they're on and
make their own films internally or go
acquire a new company
someone said this is like a who cares
thing
ev
makers make money companies like riveon
lucid motors that i believe hasn't
delivered a single car to customers
bisker will finally deliver a meaningful
number of cars first of all tesla
already makes money so they that's right
it's very clear why they didn't put him
in there so yes drew a believer do you
think all these companies start to turn
a profit or a major profit if i was to
sit down and list out and and you said
to me hey pom can you name a bunch of
[ __ ] coins in crypto and i just started
writing down things i thought were
highly highly overvalued and probably
not sustainable you'd be like oh okay
that's the list of [ __ ] coins if you
said to me can you please list the
equivalent [ __ ] coins in the public
markets the first place i would go is go
look at all of these [ __ ] companies
that are trading in the public markets
there are literally companies on this
list i will not name which one that are
trading at like 10 15 20 billion dollar
valuations they've never delivered a
single car they're giving you revenue
projections for 2027 and they're not
profitable by then and literally
investors are out here pimping them like
uh just like the [ __ ] coins say i'm the
next bitcoin these guys like we're the
next tesla like it's literally the same
you know [ __ ] and so when you look
at it i just don't think that uh the
majority of these companies are
profitable by the end of 2022 i think
the more interesting bet would be how
many of these vehicle how many of these
people deliver over under 5 000 cars in
2020
meme stocks are here to stay as retail
traders continue to find stocks to hype
up do you think that people will just
continuously find stocks to hype them up
i think that meme stocks are not new
berkshire hathaway is the goat meme
stock you fools literally talk about
berkshire hathaway like it's a religion
you go on mecca every year to omaha to
bow down to the equivalent of jesus and
warren buffett and you literally talk
about yourselves as i'm a warren buffett
disciple the only time i ever heard the
word disciples when i read the bible
when i was like 12 in sunday school
literally
berkshire hathaway is the meme stock
it's the goat you fools run around and
talk about oh i'm a value investor i'm a
disciple of warren buffett i'm gonna go
on my mecca to omaha every single year
like it's craziness it is a meme stock
and it trades talk to a boomer about
berkshire hathaway and i swear to god
you think that you offended their god
like they get pissed and they trade
whatever warren buffett does i'm in like
the guy literally panic sold the
airlines at the bottom of uh the
pandemic he's not invaluable
now i will say for years he had now
performed the s p500 over the last 12
months or so he has been out performing
it so maybe he hasn't lost this touch
they've gotten more into technology
there's a whole bunch of things but it's
a meme stock it's just not called a meme
stock because the boomers didn't know
what memes were and they're still
running around calling them mimi's but
it's still a meme stock it's just from a
different [ __ ] generation